I cannot afford to rent here anymore
there are no Flats available at the
moment I don't have the money to Fork
out to rent privately they're part of
the so-called race for space a tiny
studio flat 1 200 a month a UK rental
crisis with fewer homes more renters
soaring prices I took it without viewing
it
because that's the difference between
having a house and not having a house
Sky News analysis shows there are a
third fewer homes listed for rent than
in 2019 with prices up by a fifth I
never thought in a million years I'd I'd
be 38 homeless with two children for
Eleanor it means she's priced out
evicted in a few days from her rental in
Manchester there's nothing really in
this area which is going to be a bit of
an issue because this kid's schools are
in the area I work in the area I've been
told I could be like the other side of
Manchester if I was to go with a b and b
and then obviously that's traveling to
get to school I think it's just the
unknown of like where we're going to be
living listings are down in all big
cities Manchester is one of ten where
they've Fallen by 40 or more Bradford is
worst listings down 52 and Rental
inquiries up six-fold
why Bradford well here landlords trapped
in negative equity after the last
housing crash are only just emerging
it's kind of got to a point where
they've all gone perfect prices have
gone up I've got all these issues with
my tenants I just want to get rid of my
properties now and those landlords are
not in it as business and doing it
solely we call them at a e landlords are
doing it because they had to do they've
sold them up because they just didn't
want to do it in the first place and
it's a perfect time for them to to get
rid now but it's also about housing
supply and demand not just here in
Bradford but everywhere there simply
Aren't Enough homes being built to keep
up with the population in addition
landlords are leaving the rental market
anyway due to mortgage rate Rises and
changes in tax and legislation and it's
led to the perfect storm leading to
higher rental prices and an increasingly
competitive market Bristol is typical
listings down by a fifth inquiries
double nationally they're four times
higher
yeah I won't need to take your photo to
the landlord and then he'll make the
decision bidding wars are the norm a bit
demoralizing yeah
we keep going to places at the end of
the day we are called uh maybe we didn't
meet up to the requirements they were
looking for is either they don't want a
student or they don't want a couple yeah
they don't want exactly different
reasons the Prime Minister signaled a
move away from National house building
Targets in favor of local reform
acknowledging supply issues now
stretching to rural areas increased
transport costs or they share with
people they don't know or they end up
sofa surfing there really is a crisis in
our renting system it's another
indicator of why the government needs to
build more homes and stick to its Target
of 300 000 homes a year continued rent
Rises are unsustainable and if they go
on for many more the Specter of
homelessness will become reality Adele
Robinson Sky News